estas máquinas de manera diferente,
y por lo tanto, podemos hacer videos del flujo sanguíneo
microscópico de miles de sitios independientes en el cerebro.
Bueno, ¿y eso qué tiene que ver? Pues que los
cambios en la actividad neural, las cosas que hacen que tu cerebro funcione,
las cosas que hacen que el software de tu cerebro trabaje,
están completamente correlacionadas con los cambios de flujo sanguíneo.
Si haces un video del flujo sanguíneo, tienes una representación
independiente de actividad cerebral.
Esto literalmente ha revolucionado a la ciencia cognitiva.
No importa el área cognitiva, sea la memoria,
la planificación motora, pensar acerca de tu suegra,
molestarse con alguien, una reacción emocional, la lista es infinita,
pongan a alguien dentro de una máquina de imágenes por resonancia magnética funcional,
e imaginen cómo estas variables mapean la actividad cerebral.
Aún está en una etapa inicial, y es rudimentaria en cierto modo,
pero de hecho, hace 20 años, no estábamos en nada.
No se podía examinar a la gente de esta manera. No se podían examinar a personas sanas.
Eso ha causado una revolución que nos ha llevado a
una preparación experimental nueva. Los neurobiólogos,
como bien saben, experimentan con una gran cantidad de animales,
lombrices y roedores y moscas de la fruta y cosas así.
Y ahora, tenemos un nuevo objeto de estudio: los seres humanos.
Ahora podemos usar a los seres humanos para estudiar y hacer modelos
del software en los seres humanos, y tenemos algunas
medidas biológicas prometedoras.
Muy bien, déjenme darles un ejemplo de la clase de experimentos que se hacen,
y es en el área conocida como valoración.
Valoración es justo lo que están pensando, ¿muy bien?
Si vas a valorar dos compañías entre sí,
lo que necesitas saber es cuál es más valiosa.
Las culturas descubrieron el factor clave de la valoración hace miles de años.
Si quieres comparar naranjas con parabrisas, ¿qué tienes que hacer?
Bueno, uno no puede comparar naranjas con parabrisas.
Son objetos no miscibles. No se mezclan entre sí.
Por lo tanto, hay que pasarlos a una escala monetaria común,
ponerlos en tal escala, y valorarlos de acuerdo a esta.
Pues tu cerebro tiene que hacer algo parecido también,
y ahora estamos comenzando a entender e identificar
los sistemas cerebrales ligados a la valoración,
y uno de ellos posee un sistema neurotransmisor
cuyas células están localizadas en el tronco del encéfalo
y que le suministran dopamina al resto de tu cerebro.
No entraré en detalle, pero este es un descubrimiento
importante, y ahora sabemos un poco acerca de este proceso,
y es tan solo una pequeña parte, pero es importante porque
esas son las neuronas que perderías si tuvieras mal de Parkinson,
y son también las neuronas que son atacadas literalmente
por todo estupefaciente, y eso tiene mucho sentido.
Los estupefacientes entran y cambian
la manera en que valoras el mundo. Cambian la manera en que
valoras los símbolos asociados con tu droga preferida,
y te hacen valorar eso sobre todo lo demás.
Aquí está la parte clave. Estas neuronas también están
involucradas en la manera en que tú le das valor a ideas abstractas,
y acá puse algunos símbolos a los que les asignamos
valor por varias razones.
Nosotros tenemos un superpoder de conducta en nuestro cerebro,
que en parte utiliza dopamina.
Nosotros podemos ignorar todos nuestros instintos de supervivencia por una idea,
por una mera idea. Ninguna otra especie puede hacer eso.
En 1997, la secta Heaven's Gate cometió un suicidio en masa
basado en la idea de que había una nave espacial
escondida en la cola del en ese entonces visible cometa Hale-Bopp
que los llevaría a otro mundo. Fue un evento increíblemente trágico.
Más de dos tercios de ellos tenían títulos universitarios.
Pero el punto importante acá es que ellos fueron capaces de ignorar sus instintos de supervivencia
usando exactamente los mismos sistemas que fueron puestos
para que sobrevivieran. Eso es un gran nivel de control, ¿muy bien?
Una cosa que he omitido de esta narrativa
es lo obvio, que es el tema central del resto de mi
breve charla, y es nada menos que las otras personas.
Estos mismos sistemas de valoración son desplegados
cuando estamos valorando las interacciones con otras personas.
Entonces este mismo sistema de dopamina que nos vuelve adictos a las drogas,
que hace que te petrifiques cuando tienes mal de Parkinson,
que contribuye a varias formas de psicosis,
es también desplegado para valorar las interacciones con otras personas
y asignarle valor a los gestos que haces
cuando estás interactuando con otra persona.
Déjenme darles un ejemplo de lo anterior.
La cantidad de poder de procesamiento que tú despliegas
en esta área es enorme y ni siquiera te das cuenta.
Déjenme darle algunos ejemplos. Acá vemos a una bebé.
Ella tiene tres meses de edad. Aún se hace popó en los pañales y no puede hacer cálculos matemáticos.
Es familiar mía. Alguien está muy feliz de que ella haya salido en esta pantalla.
Uno puede cubrir uno de sus ojos, y seguir viendo
algo en el otro ojo, y yo veo curiosidad
en un ojo, y quizás un poco de sorpresa en el otro.
Acá tenemos a una pareja. Ellos están compartiendo un momento,
e incluso hemos hecho un experimento cortando
las partes de este cuadro, y uno aún puede ver
que ellos están compartiendo el momento más o menos en paralelo.
Los elementos de la foto también nos comunican eso,
pero puedes verlo sin duda alguna en sus caras,
y si comparas sus caras con otras normales, las pistas serían muy sutiles.
Esta es otra pareja. Él se está proyectando hacia nosotros,
y ella claramente proyecta, ustedes saben,
amor y admiración hacia él.
Esta es otra pareja. (Risas)
Y creo que no hay amor o admiración viniendo del lado izquierdo. (Risas)
De hecho, yo sé que ella es su hermana, y uno puede adivinar
lo que él está pensando, "Muy bien, solo estamos juntos porque posamos
para la cámara, pero luego te robarás mis dulces y me golpearás en la cara". (Risas)
Él me va a matar por haber mostrado esto.
Muy bien, ¿entonces esto qué significa?
Significa que nosotros desplegamos una enorme cantidad de poder de procesamiento en cada problema.
Conecta sistemas en el fondo de nuestro cerebro, en sistemas
dopaminérgicos que están ahí para que busques sexo, comida y sal.
Te mantienen vivo. Les da el empuje, les da
el tipo de poder de conducta al que hemos llamado superpoder.
¿Entonces cómo podemos tomar eso y montar una especie
de interacción social simulada y convertirla en una indagación científica?
Y la respuesta corta es, con juegos.
Juegos de economía. Lo que hacemos entonces es tocar dos áreas.
Un área la llamamos economía experimental. La otra es llamada economía conductual.
Les robamos los juegos y los manipulamos para nuestros propios fines.
Acá vemos uno en particular llamado el juego del ultimátum.
A la persona de rojo se le dan 100 dólares que los puede
compartir con la persona de azul. Digamos que el de rojo quiere quedarse con 70,
y le ofrece 30 al de azul. Entonces él ofrece una partición de 70-30 al de azul.
El control se le pasa al de azul, quien dice, "acepto,"
y en este caso recibiría el dinero. O el de azul dice,
"lo rechazo," y en este caso nadie recibe nada. ¿Está bien?
Pues una decisión racional, dirían los economistas, sería
tomar todas las propuestas que no sean nulas.
¿Qué hace la gente? La gente es indiferente a la partición 80-20.
En 80-20, se lanza una moneda así aceptes o no.
¿Por qué? Porque tienes rabia.
Estás molesto. Es una oferta injusta, y tú sabes lo que es una oferta injusta.
Este es el tipo de juego que se hace en mi laboratorio y en muchos otros alrededor del mundo.
Les da un ejemplo de la clase de cosas
que estos juegos indagan. Lo interesante es que estos juegos
requieren que tú tengas un gran aparato cognitivo en ese momento.
Tienes que ser capaz de posicionarte con un modelo adecuado de la otra persona,
tienes que ser capaz de recordar lo que haz hecho,
tienes que estar de pie en ese momento para poder hacerlo,
luego tienes que actualizar tu modelo basándote en las señales que te están llegando,
y tienes que hacer algo que es muy interesante,
y es que tienes que hacer una especie de evaluación.
O sea, tienes que decidir lo que la otra persona está esperando de ti.
Tienes que enviar señales para manipular tu imagen en la mente de ellos.
Como una entrevista de trabajo. Te sientas en frente del escritorio de alguien,
ese alguien tiene una imagen previa tuya,
tú le envías señales para que perciba la imagen
que tú quieres proyectar.
Somos tan buenos para eso que ni siquiera nos damos cuenta.
Este tipo de indagaciones intensifican ese proceso. ¿Muy bien?
Al hacer esto hemos descubierto que los seres humanos
son como canarios en momentos de intercambio social.
Los canarios eran usados como biosensores en las minas.
Cuando los niveles de metano o de dióxido de carbono se acumulaban,
o si el oxígeno disminuía, los pájaros eran los primeros
en desmayarse, y por lo tanto servían como un sistema de aviso:
Eh, salgan de la mina. Esto va para mal.
Las personas vienen a estos juegos, y aunque estas toscas
interacciones sociales sean montadas, y lo son, y tan solo sean
números que se intercambian entre los participantes,
las personas despliegan una gran sensibilidad.
Entonces nos dimos cuenta que podíamos aprovecharnos de esto, y en realidad,
mientras lo hemos hecho, y lo hemos hecho en
miles de personas, creo que más o menos a unas
cinco o seis mil personas. De hecho, para hacer tal
indagación biológica, necesitamos un número mayor,
mucho mayor. De todas maneras
hay patrones que han salido a flote, y hemos podido tomar
esos patrones, convertirlos en modelos matemáticos,
y usarlos para tener nuevos puntos de vista
acerca de estos intercambios. Bueno, ¿y esto qué importancia tiene?
Lo importante es que es una medida de conducta clara,
los juegos de economía nos dan claves de juego óptimo,
podemos computarlas durante el juego,
y podemos usarlas para moldear el comportamiento en cierto grado.
He aquí lo estupendo. Hace seis o siete años
creamos un equipo. En ese momento se reunía en Houston, Texas.
Hoy se reúne en Virginia y en Londres. Y construímos un software
que permite conectar los aparatos de imágenes por resonancia magnética funcional
a internet. Creo que ya hemos conectado unas seis máquinas,
pero enfoquémonos en estas dos.
Entonces sincroniza máquinas en cualquier lugar del mundo,
nosotros sincronizamos las máquinas, las preparamos
para las interacciones sociales simuladas, y monitoreamos
cada uno de los cerebros que están interactuando.
Y por vez primera, no necesitamos enfocarnos en los promedios de los participantes,
o de ponerlos a jugar en la computadora, o tratar de llegar
a inferencias de esa manera. Podemos estudiar díadas por separado.
Podemos estudiar la manera en que una persona interactúa con otra persona,
desplegar los datos, y obtener una mejor comprensión
acerca de los parámetros de cognición normal.
Pero más importante aún, es que podemos poner a personas
con enfermedades mentales específicas, o con daño cerebral,
en estas interacciones sociales y usarlas para generar investigaciones.
Nos hemos dedicado entonces a esta labor y creo que hemos obtenido,
aunque sean pocos, algunos descubrimientos embriónicos.
Creemos que hay un futuro en esto. Pero es nuestra manera
de ir redefiniendo, con un nuevo léxico,
y uno matemático para ser preciso, a comparación de
la manera tradicional en que describimos las enfermedades mentales,
caracterizando estas enfermedades usando a las personas
como canarios en estos intercambios. O sea, aprovechamos
que un participante sano jugando con otro que sufre de depresión,
o jugando con alguien que padezca de trastorno del espectro autista,
o con alguien que posea trastorno por déficit de atención con hiperactividad,
nos sirva como una especie de biosensor, y luego utilizamos
programas de computadora para modelar a esa persona,
obteniendo así una evaluación de esto.
Son las primeras etapas, pero estamos estableciendo sitios
alrededor del mundo. Acá pueden ver algunos de nuestros sitios de colaboración.
Su centro, irónicamente,
está localizado en la pequeña Roanoke, Virginia.
Hay otro centro en Londres en este momento, y el resto
están en desarrollo. Esperamos revelar los datos
en determinado momento. Hacerlos accesibles al resto
del mundo es un tema complejo.
Pero también estamos estudiando una pequeña parte
de lo que nos hace interesantes a los seres humanos, y
quiero invitar a las personas que estén interesadas en esto
para preguntarnos por el software, o para una orientación
de cómo seguir adelante con esto.
Permítanme dejarlos con un reflexión para concluir.
Lo interesante acerca del estudio de la cognición
es que hemos estado limitados en cierto modo.
Simplemente no hemos tenido las herramientas para estudiar cerebros
interactuando simultáneamente.
La realidad, sin embargo, es que incluso cuando estamos solos,
somos criaturas completamente sociales. No somos una mente solitaria
construida mediante propiedades que la mantienen viva en el mundo
independiente de otras personas. De hecho, nuestras mentes
dependen de otras personas. Ellas dependen de otras personas,
y son expresadas en otras personas,
entonces la noción de lo que tú eres, solo te es clara
justo en el momento en el que te ves interactuando con otras personas
cercanas a ti, personas que sean enemigas tuyas,
personas que te vean con reserva.
Entonces este primer bosquejo nos permite entender
lo que nos hace humanos, convertirlo en una herramienta,
y generar nuevas perspectivas acerca
de las enfermedades mentales. Gracias por invitarme. (Aplausos)
(Aplausos)